en directo a conectamos con nuestro
corresponsales en Centroamérica Andrés
Suárez porque en El Salvador se inauguró
una de las prisiones más grandes de
América Latina el llamado centro de
confinamiento del terrorismo tiene una
capacidad para 40.000 reos cuando en 20
prisiones que hay en el país caben
30.000 además tan solo durante el estado
de excepción que Comenzó desde marzo de
2022 Han detenido a 62 mil personas para
hablar del tema vamos entonces a ciudad
de Guatemala Andrés buenas noches y
cuéntanos cuáles son los detalles detrás
de la construcción de esta mega prisión
María Clara esta ha sido la noticia de
la semana en El Salvador la inauguración
de una mega cárcel que Se presume de ser
la más grande de América esto en
palabras de el ministro de Obras
Públicas salvadoreño Romeo Rodríguez Y
es que para tener una idea de su tamaño
de su dimensión el ministro dijo que en
los predios se construyeron sobre 23
hectáreas completamente aisladas esto
sería el equivalente a siete canchas de
fútbol y en esta semana en un vídeo que
publicó el presidente nayib bukele se le
vio recorriendo el predio recorriendo la
cárcel con diferentes funcionarios
justamente para mostrar que en esta
cárcel que tendrá capacidad para 40.000
prisioneros no habrá zonas de recreación
no habrá patios no habrá salas para
encuentros conyugales Pero lo que sí
habrá es zonas de trabajo pesado para
que los prisioneros de acuerdo con el
gobierno tengan la posibilidad de
resarcir el daño que le han a El
Salvador este centro de confinamiento
del terrorismo como fue bautizado por
bukele según él dice que los prisioneros
no podrán dar órdenes no podrán escapar
porque las celdas fueron construidas en
muros de concreto revestidas de varillas
de acero además hay cercas
electrificadas con 15.000 voltios 19
Torres de vigilancia que están además
Pues con muchos soldados 650 de ellos 20
más de 250 policías en síntesis es un
alcatraz prácticamente un lugar al que
se entra pero no se podría salir de allí
Andrés y cuéntenos todo esto es producto
también de la política y la guerra
contra las pandillas que ha liderado el
gobierno de nayib bukele y de allí que
haya tantas personas detenidas Cuál es
el balance que se puede hacer de esta
guerra contra las pandillas
todo indica María clara que después de
10 meses de régimen de excepción en El
Salvador nayib bukele Ha logrado su
cometido su empresa de desestructurar
por completo a las pandillas
precisamente el diario El Faro uno de
los medios salvadoreños reconocidos por
su periodismo investigativo muy crítico
de bukele y cuyas investigaciones le han
valido el premio Gabo el premio rey de
España publicó hoy una investigación en
la que aseguran que en El Salvador ya no
hay pandillas por lo menos como se
conocía anteriormente esta investigación
muestra que en San Salvador todas las
zonas donde se encontraban las pandillas
Mara Salvatrucha Trece 13 las dos
facciones de barrio 18 que son los
Sureños y los revolucionarios y otras
pandillas menores pues ya no tienen y ya
no operan allí ya no tienen influencia y
en 14 comunidades de todo el país que
estas pandillas controlaban todas las
fronteras Pues ahora se respira aire de
ya no hay extorsiones lo que quiere
decir que se ha cumplido ese cometido el
presidente bukele Claro está con graves
denuncias al de los Derechos Humanos